one guy they always go back to
yes don't try and deny that that's your
favorite expression alone that's that's
I don't think that that's just because
he's got so much experience in banging
girls I don't think that that's not just
in banging you
there's always a guy that you go back to
in between your relationships because
you know that just like come on press
the buttons no it's because you know
he's available at any time you you know
at any time
you can just call him and he'll come
back he did it side men all over the gas
everywhere the biggest podcast on in UK
right now of KSI what are they called
sidemen
wow because people want to be PC and
politically correct for the internet but
in reality
in the truth when you are on that Ray
and nephew and you think do I go home or
do I catch this 15 pound Uber to his
crib so is it fair to say women create
these side men or help the situation
because you just said you go back to a
guy several times in different
relationships so this is over a span of
six four years six years this is it
could be women yeah what's that women
control that what's the longest you've
gone back to a guy how many years
so I don't have to meet random new
people to go back to someone I've known
this is familiar he's a familiar
would you guys rather have a girl with a
higher body count or a guy that she goes
back to in between relationships
would you rather have a girl with a
higher body count or a girl with a guy
that she goes back to in between
relationships
um um I would I would say a higher body
count for the question only only for the
question holy because you're saying
about being in a relationship right
like you said that dude owns her he owns
her soul he owns your soul
he owns yourself
Yo listen the devil doesn't need to be
with you to own yourself yeah this is
this is your soul is mine yeah this is
this is this is why it's so hard to make
a woman
this is why it's so hard to please a
woman because the second you do it right
she is yours if a girl was in front of
you but yeah what you're saying is that
he's doing it right like he's doing it
so amazing that I have to keep coming
back I've just told you it's a person of
convenience
so he was not the best sex you've ever
had no if he's like a person of
convenience so someone that I know that
I can if I'm single I can call you what
about you
have I done that how long uh six years
six years wow this is not what they're
saying it is really excitement stuff
wait wait wait wait wait wait so how um
would you say was he the best sex you've
ever had yes okay I think that's why I
wouldn't have called him a side man no
that's not a definition is he an
ex-boyfriend yes okay so why aren't you
with him
um
because of Lifestyle
okay because he's taking more than one
Soul because us sidemen like to collect
Souls what do you mean like he doesn't
make enough
no as in he
wants to go out every weekend and
collect souls and stuff like that oh so
he I'm not interested in that like I
don't want someone who's partying every
weekend no thank you because there's a
high opportunity there's a high
possibility go and get whatever girl you
want because if I wanted you I'd still
have you no see women it's sad that
women played a role of that person for
six years playing this game with them
and they still complain about a
lifestyle or this and that but fed into
that same ego anyway well I didn't
because I wasn't his girlfriend I was
just someone who never before you played
role of his girlfriend kind of like from
the men's point of view it's like it
women like we want relationships men
want sex so you're giving him what he
wants without getting anything from it
so it's like you're playing into him
being a player and like having multiple
women because you keep going back
and I'm not like judging you for it it's
just like that's how the guys see it
and I mean it kind of makes sense you
know what I mean yeah they've got it
perfect from their their point of view
and I get that but if if I wanted a
relationship with him I could have been
in a relationship like wow sorry what we
control the relationship no we couldn't
we determine who is wifey that is the
only Power left did he ask you to be his
girlfriend
he said during it yeah like I think that
that we can be together and I was like
nah okay so he said I want you to be my
girlfriend and then you said no um okay
um oh why because of his lifestyle I'm
not interested in that lifestyle just
for sex though that lifestyle was good
yeah but it's not just about sex is it
what I want as as a future is not just
sex so that was great and convenient but
it's not all I want okay
would you take what you want
over sex though
yeah what if a guy had everything you
wanted but bad sex
yeah
um no no no no no and I repeat side men
own the soul do you think I know do you
think like we're sold a dream
like you can't have everything so it's
like we want a guy that's good at sex
good career but also good at sex but
doesn't talk to a bunch of girls to get
good at sex
tall makes good money yeah and and we
don't want to compete for them
yes I don't have that many stipulations
I have that you don't need to be six
foot and I'm quite thingy I'm like
chilled what's your what's your what are
your standards
I don't have like oh you don't need to
earn more than me you don't need to be
tall and be okay whatever I don't I just
like individuals for who they are like
it's just a connection 20 000 pounds a
year you're dating them
yeah really
yeah twenty thousand I've lived by
myself like since I was 17 I've looked
after myself so you don't I don't really
need anything from you okay so so your
course low income yeah I don't mind yeah
okay yeah I don't know what I need for
it I don't prefer
um bums but you definitely
yeah but not everyone just has a come up
not everyone's gonna be 50 Grand 100
Grand a year just like that and I
understand that because I've been
someone who has been on a low income and
I've had to work really hard some people
have to work extra hard I'm saying like
he's stuck at it's not like he's gonna
get better it's like he's at that for
Life yeah but then he can be the house
husband and I can go to work oh no
that's why I mean that's the least yeah
you're compromising on something yeah
but it's just like and I mean that's
probably why you're that's why I say
individual to this the person because
someone could be on a low income but if
I if I'm the higher and he's happy to
stay home and be the stay-at-home dad
and have the kids then we still win wins
because I still get my career he gets to
look after the kids
would you guys do that be a house
husband no wait no way
all right well it depends he's like
maybe it depends for a time of your life
you know you might have to be at home
what's wrong with that it's not wrong
for a portion yeah a proportion that
might not be it might not be too bad but
if a house has been like suggests that
you that is what you do
no that is it that is the only thing
that you're doing no for for the
foreseeable future you're raising these
Jokers raising children is is a long
term it's a long-term commitment so
we're talking about
maybe until that child is able to film
for themselves kind of when they go
secondary school that kind of time no if
we're talking about being a house
husband up until then I don't know about
that I don't think that the woman would
look at you you're asking to make it
they're gonna look that that was asking
for it your woman's gonna look at you
like you're a [ __ ] absolutely
where's my dinner
like why why
are the kids asleep that's an ego thing
isn't it though absolutely it's like
Power Balance and how yes yes you have
your relationship with that person so
it's individual no you're talking about
exceptions to the rule as men hell no no
no no no we're not even yeah
that's what I'm saying so biologically
we couldn't even deal with it like our
level of tolerance as much I know a lot
of um House people house husbands how
many oh and I know a lot of men who are
the um main caregivers of their kids
more than five
yeah you know more than five yeah it's
interesting because women make less than
men and we spend more so we're not
really good with money I don't think
most women would do well as the head of
household
they don't a lot of people like my
friends
um who she's a lawyer and I can't
remember what her husband died and when
they decide to have kids he stayed home
and she's because she was the higher
earner so it financially worked better
for them no and that's uh if I'm I'm all
for people who should do what they want
to do so if that works for them but it's
just the number one reason that people
get divorced and women tend to leave men
after they out earn them and one of the
another indicator that you're going to
get divorced is that like a woman gets a
promotion at work
well people are just superficial what
can I say
I don't know if it's superficial I think
it's in our biology partially in biology
yeah yeah it's like the world is trying
to argue with like God's nature but you
can't argue with that you just can't
even in like if you look at you take it
to the white if you ever get stuck when
the world was created there wasn't money
though so of course it was it was trade
we have trade money would you guys this
currency is what we as human beings
decide currency is so back in the day if
I had 50 wives which they used to have
but no cattle and and and and scoop over
there had a hundred cattle I mean like
bro Shanika shanicho I'll be getting on
my nerves for the last six months take
them and give me some of those cows and
that's trade that's currency that's how
we used to get things going back in the
day that's how it was this is why you
would hear about biblical men having a
thousand wives you weren't smashing a
thousand of them what it was is that
they were connected to his name which
provided status power and as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible